I PULLED A LOT OF STRINGS
TO HELP GET YOU THIS GIG.
HEY, BABY.
IT'S MY GIRLFRIEND'S
GRANDSON'S PARTY,
SO DON'T SCREW IT UP.
- DON'T WORRY.
THE KIDS WILL LOVE IT.
I'M DOING A SONG I WROTE ABOUT
GUYS WHO WORK ON A MOUNTAIN.
- ALL RIGHT.
NOW GO GET 'EM.
- [clears throat]
♪ MOUNTAIN MEN
I LOVE MOUNTAIN MEN ♪
♪ MOUNTIN' HARRY, MOUNTIN' TOM,
AND MOUNTIN' BEN ♪
♪ SHARING A TENT
WITH MY FAVORITE DUDES ♪
♪ I WANT TO BE
MOUNTIN' MEN LIKE YOU ♪
♪ THEY'RE SWEATY, HAIRY,
AND HARD AS A ROCK ♪
- STEVE, WHAT THE HELL?
YOU BETTER
PLAY SOMETHING ELSE QUICK!
SOMETHING FOR THE KIDS.
- OOH, I'VE GOT
A CUTE ROOSTER SONG.
- DO IT! DO IT!
- ♪ I'M IN THE BARN,
I'M PLAYING WITH MY COCK ♪
♪ ALL THE BOYS LINE UP
TO PET MY COCK ♪
♪ HE'S THICK, HE'S RED,
HE'S GOT A BIG OLD HEAD ♪
♪ WHY DON'T I JUST
SHOW YOU INSTEAD? ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR HAND
IF YOU WANT TO SEE MY COCK ♪
- KILL HIM!
- LET'S GET HIM!
- RUN, STEVE, RUN!
- WHAT'D I SAY?
WHAT'D I SAY?
THEY HATE ME.
WHY DID THEY HATE ME?
- STEVE, DIDN'T YOU THINK
THERE WAS SOMETHING...
QUEER ABOUT THOSE SONGS?
- I JUST WRITE
WHOLESOME COUNTRY SONGS.
SEE?
- FARMHAND JOBS.
COME IN MY BACK DOOR, BUBBA.
RIDING THE BOLOGNA PONY?
- WHAT'D I TELL YOU?
- HMM.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK YOU JUST NEED
A CHANGE OF VENUE.
- ♪ YOU SAY LOVE
♪ IS EASY
♪
♪ BUT LOVE
IS PAINFUL ♪
CAN MAKE YOU CRY ♪
♪ BUT LOVE
CAN LEAVE YOU BLOODY ♪
♪ IT'S NOT EASY
♪ BUT LOVE
FILLS YOU UP INSIDE ♪
[crowd cheers and whistles]